board. And here we go. Welcome to another Zoom call, everyone. Just a reminder to check
the member site for announcements like last week's announcement that we were not able to
have a Zoom call. Also, another reminder, if you're going to do an educational coaching call, a call
with me, you can pay for an online, you have to fill out that coaching call request form.
Same thing with, there's a cheek swab request form that you have to fill out. So,
it's not the people that regularly are on this call that make that mistake, but a lot of people
that may not listen to the calls or something that they don't have to remind them. So make sure that
the forms are filled out. Also, a reminder, the courses are available for everybody. So,
you're a full member. You have availability of all the courses. Go to that and, of course,
the blogs. The big news is the right update. We've recommended, for most people, just to stay with
the right program you're running with version 6.0. Some people who have been with us longer and
are still running a 5.0 program that really needs to be updated. Updating your computer and such,
all the information in the videos and such are on the member site. So, look at the member site
for information whether you should update it. Everybody's missed the deadline now to update your
F1117. If you started with us in the last four years, you have an F122, but before that, you might
have an F1117 and you had that opportunity to update it. We sent out an email and sorted to
RIF and so that would close down. Okay, let's get to the questions. By one breast is
the need completely eaten away by the cancer slowly but surely, is that normal? Well, it's never
normal. Is it common? Yes, it's common. So, as the cancer is continuing to grow, it can be
basically kind of devouring the rest of the breast tissue. That's actually a better scenario
than the two were just getting larger and larger and larger. So, that's when the cancer is continuing to
grow and the breast is getting kind of eaten away, that's actually a better scenario than the
scenario of the breast, the two were getting larger and larger and larger. We've seen plenty of
that over the years that is a little scarier and doesn't always have as best outcome.
You've seen this happen with other women with breast cancer and their breast seems the tissue
seems to just kind of get eaten away and the things stop. So, you know, you're already doing
everything you can. I know you've recommended you talk to your oncologist again. It seems like
they're not really giving you any solutions at all. I am a surgery really isn't probably even
offered to you at this time. So, I don't know that I would change anything. I know this person that
we have just talked recently. So, I don't think there's anything else to change.
I was recently reviewing my genetic summary. Near the beginning, under the section,
Peter's bolded caffeine, it says to avoid or limit caffeine,
text is bolded but not highlighted. Okay, so this is the genetic summary. So, those of you that have
started with us in the last couple years, you know that you receive a full genetic report that you
receive a genetic summary, and then you receive a genetic action steps. So, in the genetic summary,
the only thing you need to pay attention to is the highlighted pieces. If it's not highlighted,
you don't need to pay attention to it. It wasn't an issue with your genes. Later in this section,
onto our suppressor genes, the HIF1A, it mentions that caffeine is a possible intervention. What should
I make of this? Also, if that wasn't highlighted, you could ignore both those things. If it was highlighted,
then caffeine. So, just so you know, with HIF1A genes, caffeine can help that gene work better.
So, that's another reason why I have told all of you that drinking a little coffee is okay. I know
there's natural paths out there and natural doctors that curse coffee and think coffee is just this
evil beast that's destroying our health. That's not me, I don't believe that. If you look at any of
the latest dud bias studies, it actually shows that coffee can be beneficial for a lot of things.
However, caffeine itself, if you have the genes of that first page in that summary, I don't remember
the gene. It is that gene family. If you don't, and I highlighted that, then caffeine needs to be
watched a little closer. So, if you have a specific gene defect, you actually detox coffee
quite well. I used to tell people, before that gene was identified, you could tell if a person
detoxifies caffeine well as if they drink coffee and they have to urinate. So, yeah, I love coffee.
But, yeah, typically if I drink a couple cups of coffee, I have to go pee. Well, that's a good thing.
You're getting rid of it. Over the years of me practicing over the last 35 plus years,
I've had people, I remember this one guy, this is not a cancer patient. Decades ago, and you drink
seven cups of coffee a day. That cups pots of coffee a day. This guy was a blue collar worker.
He's the funniest guy in the world. I just loved this guy. He had rheumatoid arthritis.
And he had a serious coffee addiction. But I asked him, are you going to go to the bathroom all day?
No, coffee doesn't make him pee at all. Well, caffeine was an issue with his rheumatoid arthritis.
He had an addiction to caffeine. And caffeine would stimulate, you know, more damage to his
joint capsule cell. So, we had to get him to cut way back on his caffeine and just cutting back on his
caffeine. There's no way we were going to eliminate it in his life. He just wasn't willing to do that,
but it made a big difference in his symptoms. So, I don't think everybody should be drinking, you know,
a ton of caffeine every day, but a little bit of caffeine can actually be beneficial for the HIF-1
aging. So, that's all I say about that. So, read the instructions at the top of your
genetic summary. It says to really, you're only looking at the highlighted genes,
that the highlighted genes are the ones that you have issues with. Nothing else.
I'm getting ready to submit a second cheek swab for supplement recommendations. How does one know
what it might be a good time to do a rife update? But almost a year, but faithfully using it,
but doing well, but my PSA is recently going up. So, it depends on the cancer. So,
for prostate cancer, really the only time you need to do a rife update for prostate cancer
is if there's metastasis. So, if there's no metastasis with prostate cancer, with other cancers,
it depends. If the person's getting worse, it's good to check that rife update. They don't check and see
if you need a rife update. They don't do it. So, a lot of you said in your cheek swab forms and you
check general recommendations. You might make some notes and you might check rife update too,
and you don't need a rife update. So, we don't charge you for a rife update.
So, you could check that and I'll check most likely the answers. No, you won't need it.
I don't glad they check and see. What do you think of the gallery test? So, I'm very familiar with
the gallery test. I've had the rep contact the multiple times I met with the rep one time.
The gallery test does it interest me at all unless the person does not know if they have cancer
and they want a good cancer screening test to find out if they have a high probability of cancer.
The gallery test does not, you cannot tell a person via the results of the gallery test that they
definitively have cancer, but you can tell a person that there's a really good chance that you
have cancer you need to go and get further investigation. So, for a person that has already been
diagnosed with cancer already knows the have cancer already has been through treatment of cancer.
To me, the gallery test is an absolutely zero value. So, really, the gallery test shines
with people who, hey, I don't want to go to a doctor to find out I have cancer. I have this mess
in my breast or whatever. I don't feel good. I don't, I don't, I don't, I just feel like in my
doctor something wrong. And you want a screening test, well, then the gallery test can be a good example.
There's other tests like this as well. The using the same technology is the colo, the colo guard test,
but you that one you have to go to a medical doctor and get it prescribed,
but that one only tests for colo rectal cancer. It's not this, it uses the same technology as the
IVG test for those of you who remember back four years ago when the IVG test was available.
uses DNA, recombinant technology. So, it's a valuable test, but if it does not give you a score like
the IVG test gave you, that's what made the IVG test so unique. The gallery test does not do that. So,
as far as grading your cancer, as far as knowing if you're getting better or worse, etc, there's to
be there's, for some of the originals, they have cancer, there's zero value, so that I explain
that to the rap, because we never went any further, because it's just to make any sense at all to
different patients. I have the opportunity to get folded in a therapy locally, funds allowing
how often and how many sessions is reasonable for me to, for my current condition. Both are
expensive. I was going to do the gallery because of my unexplained elevated AFP. I would not say that
the gallery is going to give you the information that you want from that, but then thought why not do
the photodynamic therapy instead at least once. So, understand photodynamic therapy that is offered,
I would investigate what tools that they're using, what equipment that they're using.
If it is true photodynamic therapy, then I would say if you have the opportunity to do one or the other,
I would do that. We've talked about this, I think this question about photodynamic therapy came up.
Oh, about six, eight months ago, there's no
patented on that term. So, photodynamic therapy means light therapy. So, there are laser
companies that are selling laser lasers as photodynamic therapy. I know that true photodynamic therapy
does use lasers, that's why it's called photodynamic therapy, but it uses a drug, a chemical, and it's
very specific to the cancer, and it's pinpointed, it's more elaborate technology than just a
level one, two, three, or four laser. So, I would investigate that, but for sure I would choose a
therapy over the test. I have a water pill, small dosage, which is not helping very much.
Doctors concerned about electrolytes. I have a recipe for one fourth of both cream of
tartar and hevelian salt with warm water. I know salt isn't the best with thyroid issues,
can you give me any suggestions? So, if you want suggestions to increase electrolytes,
so electrolytes are minerals. So, if you want to increase electrolytes, typically when you're
talking about electrolytes, in your body, you're talking a lot about sodium chloride and potassium.
So, again, how do you increase those? It is with salt. So, it is using salt. So, there's products
of the market that are for electrolytes, what do they have it? They basically have salt. So,
if your purpose is just to increase those levels, then using salt in a form of hevelian salt may be
appropriate. You've got to look at your blood test, though, and see what your low one. So,
well, no, no, no one potassium, no, no, no, sodium chloride. If sodium chloride or low, then just
taking salt is going to increase them. If not, then you don't need to do that. So, look at a blood
test, but I don't see anything wrong with doing that, and I don't see that harmony in your thyroid
gland. If you're low on sodium and chloride, you do need more salt. My understanding is that for
individuals doing radio, chemo therapy, okay, we already, this person had a conversation. So, we're
going to skip that question. Is there something safer than baby aspirin to take? So, if you're,
as a what you're why you're taking this, do you test for this with the cheek swab? I can, if you
ask specifically for it, if you're asking something to help prevent blood clots. So, can, there are,
I know there's alternative perspectives on using aspirin and using baby aspirin, which is I think
88 milligrams of acetyl cell acid to help with clotting. I don't think even from an alternative
perspective, I know there's, you know, some studies that have come out that it can damage your heart,
it can damage the blood vessels, taking it on a long-term basis, what they used to. I think they
still may recommend taking a baby aspirin, you know, every single day for people over a certain age.
I don't know if that is even, you know, recommendation anymore. I do think that with some people,
yes, it did cause cardiovascular damage, taking it on a long-term basis, but taking it for a
shorter basis because there's a potential clot formation. I don't see anything wrong with that.
Is there other things that you could do to help prevent clot formation?
Yes, things garlic is probably your number one thing to, as a blood thinner, from a nutritional
perspective. And then using lumbarochydase and danochydase, those are two enzymes that can be
very beneficial. Those are in the, both the product called clear tox and the product called clear
circulation. Clear circulation has more things for blood vessels in it, but the clear tox has more
things to help detox. It was mainly put together to help detox the, the effects of the COVID vaccine
in any RNA, DNA vaccines, but clear circulation might be another thing to think about too. And like I
said, garlic. I continued to experience vaginal dryness, which is worsening to the point that I dread
intimacy. I think it is called vaginal atrophy. I could try using a cream suggested by my thyroid
doctor, which contains a compounded vitamin A and E and hyaluronic acid, and with a tiny bit of
testosterone. Would this be safe given by diagnosis of breast cancer? What are my options?
So, from an alternative perspective, vaginal dryness or vaginal atrophy, typically the recommendation
would be bio-identical testosterone with a testosterone cream. So, is that a negative for breast cancer?
The answer is yes and no. So, there's a possibility that excess testosterone will store in your fat
cells and then through a process of a robotization will break down into the quote-unquote bad estrogen.
That could be an issue. However, that could be managed and monitored. So, there's also evidence
that using testosterone with people with breast cancer can actually have great beneficial
attributes. So, I would say absolutely go ahead with trying this cream. I would try to
cream first, because that's simple before you try to get into compounded testosterone bioidenticals.
I would go for this. I would for sure do this. Yes. At 850 milliliters taken off a long
Friday, four weeks before this, they took off 500 milliliters. The doctor says 15% of patients
have a deba with picray, chemotherapy. She left be on it, but is getting very uncomfortable.
Just can't keep the fluid under control. Going to occupational and physical therapy, both two times
a week. I have lots of indigestion when taking supplements. This just started since the radiation
on my 11th rib, unless it is the adema in my body, any suggestions. So, the fluid in your lungs,
I don't think is from inflammation in your body. I think that's a sighties from the cancer. And you
do want to monitor the amount of fluid production over time. So, the rate of fluid production.
So, if you're going in every four weeks and they're taking off 500 milliliters, then 850
milliliters, then the next time it's 12-50 milliliters, that's a concern. So, that's a red flag that
there's an increase in the production of sighties. Now, there's other ideas about this too. So,
some people will say, well, that could happen if the cancer is dying off. And, certainly, being
on a chemotherapy that could be a possibility. So, you do want to measure that side of the increase
in fluid sighties with other signs and other symptoms as well, just like, you know, judge anything
by just one test. But, if there's an increase in sighties, then that is got to be a concern at least
to be investigated. I've been taking them with warm water supplements, wise. Sometimes that helps,
and other times it just doesn't matter. I suppose it could be from the chemo pill. Certainly,
that chemo pill can cause nausea, can cause stomach upset. I don't know what that chemo pill does to
your HCL production. So, I would, first thing I would say is maybe make sure you're taking your supplements
with food and that you're taking some HCL or digestive type thing with HCL at it, with that meal to see
if that helps too. Because if you have a decrease in hydrochloric acid production, your stomach,
anything getting into your stomach, especially the capsule is going to irritate your stomach,
as you're not breaking that down quickly. So, look at that as well. The vitamin D level was tested
in last December and was found to be in the low 40s. I started taking one ADK avail almost every day
last December. It was retested again just recently and it's still in the low 40s, no improvement.
So, ADK avail has 5,000 IUs of vitamin D in it per capsule, if I remember correctly.
So, friend of mine suggested that I switch to a liquid version of vitamin D that might absorb
it better in your thoughts. I don't think you're going to absorb it better because you're actually
taking a gel cap because it breaks out into liquid immediately too. So, it's not that. I think it's
the dosage. So, I think you eat. So, I don't know what your VDR gene looks like. That's your
vitamin D receptor gene picture looks like. I'd have to pull up your genetic profile again.
If a person has defects on their VDR genes, they have a much more difficult time
utilizing an absorbed vitamin D. If, again, if your HCl production, hydrochloric acid production,
your stomach is low, you're going to have a difficult time absorbing any supplements.
Number three, if your gallbladder is cloprobized at all, either gallstones, I have my gallbladder removed,
or I don't even know that I have gallstones, I have sluggish gallbladder, whatever,
you're going to have a difficult time absorbing the fat soluble vitamins. So, if you have
low vitamin D levels and you're taking vitamin D and you can't get the vitamin D levels up,
those are some of the things you need to look at. What about vitamin D receptors genetically
look like? If they have acypropyze, you have defects, either a single or especially a double
allele defect on your VDR gene, then you have to just increase the dosage. Number two,
do I have a decreased hydrochloric acid production and decreased hydrochloric acid? Is that causing
a bowel absorption? So, it could be a bowel absorption issue. Number three, do I have gallbladder
issues and a decrease in bile production, bile is what you need to absorb fat and break down the
fats. The A, the vitamin A, the vitamin D, the vitamin K, and the vitamin E are all fat soluble vitamins
indeed, bile in order for you to be able to utilize them correctly and to get proper
absorption. So, those are the things that you want to look at. That's why I like that
clear balance. Sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry. That's why I like the clear digest. The digest
events that we have private labeled as cutters, clinic, clear digest because it has, it's just
telling us to this today, I think, because it has HCl in it. It has a good balance of enzymes
for a breakdown of proteins and carbohydrates and fats. And it has ox bile. It's the only
digestive enzyme that I've seen. There's probably others on the market that have all three of those
things. You need HCl in order to digest food in your stomach. Otherwise, that's going to go into your
into your duodenum, only partially digested and you're totally, totally sent yourself on for H
parlorian infections. You need digestive enzymes to take pressure off your, your pain crease to help
your digest anything in your food. And then how many people have sluggish gold letters? I mean,
lots. So adding that ox bile is certainly a huge help for a lot of people. So if you even,
you know, people that have no, so the person has no gold letters that are gone better removed,
then you definitely, you can go right to that. And you need more than what's in the clear digest.
You need ox bile. So get an ox bile supplement. We have them in the store.
Matter of fact, I think we have several that are near expiration date that I'll throw. I know who
asked this question. I think it's them and I will throw a bottle of that in your
next order. I want to remind Megan so I don't forget to remind her.
Because taking just taking one of those with your supplements could be the solution. And you don't
even need to increase the amount of vitamin that you're taking. Not sure if you're able to answer
this. My oncologist has me on picrate 200 milligrams. I'm having lots of the demon. She put me
on increased water pill. We asked if she would consider lowering the chemo dose because it seems to
be working, but maybe a little lower dose would do the same without as many side effects. One of
your thoughts that Earth said, she wouldn't change dose into without a scan in another month away.
Can we argue with her or just do what they say for waiting for us in the tour test, which is a
circulating tumor cell. Just to come back also are those tests pretty accurate compared to two markers.
Well, they're just totally different than two markers, but it's just another test to look at things.
Yeah, unfortunately, the personalized medicine with your oncologist is kind of just doesn't exist
very often anymore. And it's part, it's really honestly probably, you know, maybe 75% because
they are covering their butt as far as a lawsuit or in 25% that they just are not
maybe very ethnical. I don't know, but it's it's really hard to get personalized care where you can
say, hey, can we drop this down a little bit? I would just ask or try to ask and see what they say.
I mean, she might have a valid reason to say no. I want to keep you on this. You're doing well.
It's deal with the symptoms she might have, you know, kind of giving you a bunch of bloating to try
to keep you on that to keep her tail covered. So if she doesn't get in trouble with her boss, it's just
the doctors don't control things anymore. They're just pawns in the whole grand scheme of big form,
unfortunately. My homocysteine level was high at 15.6. I took methyl B12, right? So person has high
homocysteine. That's where you have to take some methyl groups, either methyl B12 or methyl folate.
They have both our methyl donors. You have to lower the homocysteine levels.
Did it for two weeks? It had a reach act and it dropped to 12.7. We'll see how fast that is.
That's remarkable. Unbelievable. So it went down, but it's still a little elevated.
Integrated Dr. Woods, we need to keep taking the methyl B12 to get it done further.
I took five days off and for the test, while waiting as a result, do you agree that I should keep
taking it or should I do another course of action? No, I agree. You should keep taking it. Get that done
further and then you can pulse it. And I don't think you should ever having that level of homocysteine,
I don't think you should ever go off of it for good. You could like go two days a week or something
like that. So maybe you're just going to do that Saturday and Sunday. And you could be able to keep
your homocysteine levels at bay that way. But you could easily do a blood test to make sure you're
keeping it at bay, but you don't want it to get elevated like that. Why? Because homocysteine
etches your interior of your epithelial cells, your walls of your artery, arteries, your endothelial
cells and damaged endothelial cells. What do they do? They have these little grooves and they collect
cholesterol. So, and then cholesterol gets to be the bad name that they're the bad guy causing these
cholesterol plaques and your artery would have really had nothing to do with cholesterol whatsoever.
It's the damaged endothelial cells. Good antibiotics help and come batting by type of cancer. So
ethymionic use is an off-label use of medication in the caroncology protocols. So
we've had people do some of those protocols for helping with cancer. It's really hard to measure
the success or not because they're doing so many other things. So it's hard to know
if maybe other people could chime in that maybe they were doing everything and their cancer
was going the wrong way and they added some of the off-label drugs and their cancer turned
eroded and started going the right way. I don't remember anybody off the top of my head that
had that experience. I got to there's maybe a few people on this call that I've done
the off-label drug use. So I don't know. As far as your particular cancer, I'm not sure, I can't make
that comment if that would be true in your case. And using the antibiotics, I don't remember. That
was one of the things that most of our patients tried. One of the off-label drugs that most of our
patients tried away from because of the damage to the microbiota that is definitely going to happen
when you're doing that. Are probiotics a better approach? Well, I don't think that probiotics is a
cancer treatment is an approach. Probiotics help your microbiota but it's not really a cancer treatment
approach. Okay, so the person that asks this question, I believe, is a person that has an open
wound. The other thing that may help with an open wound is using probiotics
topically. So I've had numerous cases where using a probiotics topically, meaning you have a
capsule that you open up, and it should not be a spore probiotics. So there should be just a regular
probiotic, not a spore probiotic, if you know the difference. So there's, it'll say it right on
the the packaging. This is probiotic spore. Typically we call spore something like i.g. spore mega
spore or something. So a done spore probiotic where you just sprinkle a little bit of the, you know,
open up a capsule and it's sprinkled that half the capsule on the wound every day.
Okay, we've had some pretty cool results with that. You could think about doing that.
But taking it orally, I don't think that's going to have much of an effect on a cancer.
Of course, unless the cancer is like, you know, in the esophagus or in the, you know, in the
DeWonville area or something like that. What do you think about a rec stump therapy? That is a medication
I legally can't even comment on that. So you suggested cutting down a lion's mane. This is a
latest cheek swab. Could you please advise why? That's just because that's what came up in the testing.
About a month now, I periodically have muscle spasms on my right shoulder.
The first three weeks had happened while I laid in bed. No, it just spasms anytime, but periodically,
could this be linked to the cancer? So this person has had a neck cancer and yes, it could be
affecting just the space-occupied lesion of the cancer, where the cancer is. It could be affected
in the brachial plexus. That's the nerve plexus that's coming out of the cervical spine. And it goes
also backwards to the rhubboids and the trapezius muscles. And that could definitely be
causing some of the spasms. Going to the chiropractor, getting those work done can be
helpful. Anything you can do to decrease inflammation could be helpful. Ice using ice, hot cold
packs could be helpful using a tens unit could be helpful. Any anti-inflammatory nutrition could
be helpful. Are there certain gene variations I should be looking at in my genetic report to see
glyphosate might be causing a problem in my body? Or is it just any of the detox related genes?
I've already taken two teaspoons of liposomal glutathione and three tablespoons of ground tuneric
per day. So the glutathione is going to help both phase one in phase two in the liver, plus it's
going to help with into a cellular detoxification of glyphosate and anything. So what gene variations
should you look at? The NAT genes, the PUN1 genes, the cytochrome P450 genes, all your detoxification
pathways, your catalyzed genes, your superoxide genes, those would be the things that you could
think of. Most people don't have glyphosate problems because they have solely because they have
genetic defects, they have glyphosate problems because they have glyphosate exposure. So you can say,
well why doesn't everybody have glyphosate problems? The answer is everybody probably does have glyphosate
problems, especially in the United States. I had a nice load conversation with Agal from Germany
who's living in the United States. No, my daughters were talking to her for quite a while. Talking
about all the pesticides and herbicides and things have been banned in Europe. So if you could get
a hold of food that's imported, you're probably better off. I took a glyphosate test since you
found it to be a possible cause. What you did by the last cheek, so I'm obsessed with the result
was 1.5, which looks to be in the 50th percentile. Is this a very bad score? Yeah, I did look at your
test. Is it a bad score? There isn't any good score when it comes to glyphosates. Let's just leave
it at that. How much do you think this could contribute to my breast cancer? Well, remember, so
what your score is today doesn't mean that's what your score was four years ago when the
kids are started growing. Why didn't you diagnose till two years ago? Yeah, I said that right. So your
kids started growing longer before you were diagnosed. So your score might have been much higher
than you've got a lot of detox work. Up to this point is that you just get the test done with your
score might have been way worse even six months ago. When you took the cheek swab, you had already
suggested increasing my clear toxins three per day. That on kale support at HMET by deer and lymph
active from cell core. I'm still doing a coffee at a memory day and you're getting to the day
time and highest quality beta can afford. I don't think there's anything else you have to do
based upon the results of those test. How important is the grounding bet in conjunction with the
rif treatments? So the grounding bet that comes with your rif machine is to be used when you use
the iron pro wave. So in my iron pro wave, everybody thinks it's just to pull
junk out of your body through your feet. No, it's to get different frequencies in your body and
doing so it does have an avenue of escape for different things as well. But the purpose of that is
to pull the frequencies into your body and you do want to put the grounding bet behind your back
when you're doing iron pro wave. That's only time you're using the grounding bet. If you have a
different grounding bet at home or at grounding sheet at home, as I have said in so many of the videos
that grounding sheets should be used on the lower half of your bed underneath the fitted
mattress, fitted sheet, the lower half of your bed underneath the fitted sheet. I got an yeast
infection from staff and antibiotics back in June and July. I have a limited fruit. I take
probiotics daily as well as probiotic and fused coconut yogurt, rectally and vaginally daily. I've
taken a whole bottle of kittas and forte. I still have very itchy exema on my eyelids,
et cetera, et cetera. What am I missing? How do I get rid of these infection? So
Candida is a very difficult thing to get rid of because systemic Candida is just a side of
other hill health too. So when you're doing other things like chemotherapy and all this stuff,
it's just really, really difficult. You have to just be patient with yourself. You're doing all
the right things. These probiotic-confused yogurt, rectally and vaginally, you're just trying to get
probiotics at every orifice of your body as what you're trying to do. And then just
all the other good things that you are doing is just a whole lot more that you could do.
We can't be adding more supplements to your protocol. You're just done so many things.
Let's wait till you get through the chemo that we can discuss possible next steps with that.
What do you think about using mistletoe injections and in fusion form? Well,
I'm all for that. So the purpose of mistletoe injections is to stimulating immune response
against the cancer. And you can start with an IV mistletoe form. That can be beneficial to get
things kick-started too. So of course it has serious cancer and you want to get an immune response
kick-started. That can be very beneficial. What are your thoughts on RSO, RIC Simpson oil?
So RIC Simpson oil is very, very highly concentrated THC from marijuana.
So RIC Simpson oil can be very beneficial. It comes in a little syringe tube because it is
like tar in its consistency. It's very, very sticky. If you let it warm up, it becomes a little less
viscous. And you can manage it a little bit better. But you've got to be careful with how much
you take. If you're going to do RIC Simpson oil, it doesn't co-direct anything else you're doing because
it's not an oxidizing agent that needs to be taken away from any antioxidants, etc. like
protocell or something. So you could do it in conjunction with anything else you're doing.
Matter of fact, we've had people do RIC Simpson oil conjunction with chemotherapy.
Now RIC Simpson oil has to be, make sure you source it from. It's a most honest source you can find
that they're actually, it's a clean process that they're using because in order to extract
the THC from the marijuana plant, you have to use some sort of extraction process.
And usually we're using something like ever clear or even I suppose alcohol. But then no hard,
no foul because you're heating it up and burning all of that off. Now a person who's making it,
if you're making it in your backyard, you would never make it in your house because you could blow up
your house. But if you're making it in your backyard where there's air flowing through, you could
choose to take shortcut and to stop the process before all the alcohol or whatever solvent you use
to extract the THC is completely burned off. And then you could actually sell more of it because
for instance, I'm getting eight ounces. Now I have 12 ounces and I'm going to be able to make more
money. So you want to buy it from somebody who is reputable enough that cares about what they're
making that's going to be highest quality for whoever's going to end point to consume it because
that solvent that they use to pull the THC out of the marijuana is toxic. You know, you could get sick
off of that. It's probably that dire anything, but you could make you ill. And the THC
concentrated THC of reccipital else going to make you ill enough at itself because you know, I don't
know anybody who's ever done reccipital oil and said, Oh, this was so pleasant. I just love it.
So it makes you feel super, super loopy. You got to start really slow just doing one great
of rice before bed per day and then move up to two and then get up to three and then a true
reccipital oil approach from reccipital is doing three grades of rice three times a day. And I know
very few people have been able to get up to that level. Personally, I've never smoked marijuana before.
I've never taken drugs. I've never done anything like that. Never hardly ever taken prescription
medication. My mom was very natural and how she raised us. That's where what made me want to do what
I'm doing. But when I was the worst of my cancer, I took reccipital oil and only for, I only did
it a couple of times because I got so unbelievably loopy. I thought I was going crazy. I just couldn't
do it. I just literally could not do it. Now I've used THC in liquid form that wasn't nearly
the concentration of reccipital oil. And even that, I didn't do well. So it's, I actually used THC
the other day because my body was hurting so bad I worked too hard in the garden and I just felt
like things flared up but I could have flared up some history and I did some reccipital oil too
because I don't like taking drugs. I don't like even taking Tylenol or anything. And I was so
unbelievably loopy the next day. I just, I don't know, I just haven't told her it's done anything. So
but not against it. We've seen people have great results with it. I just say really be careful
and go slow. I get two chemo and one immunotherapy IV every three weeks after the first two
infusions. The tubers are shrinking daily and it's amazing right. However, I just had my third IV
last Thursday. I'm not seeing either feeling the same positive changes as chemo just stop working
at some point. Well, the answer is more complex than that. The answer can be yes, the chemo can stop
working. But number two, remember, if you get so much shrinkage, it doesn't mean the chemo that
it's just going to keep going. It's going to disappear because. So maybe the cells that we're growing
are dead and now the cells that remain are not reproducing. This is my disagreement with oncologists.
You know, they just think, oh no, we're out to finish the protocol. Why? Because that's the protocol.
Well, who made the protocol? Oh, years of research. That's a bunch of bloating. You know,
made the protocol. The drug company made the protocol. That's who made the protocol.
So this is my argument. This is why I always say don't be scared of doing chemo or immunotherapy.
You could stop it anytime. Not telling you to stop, but you're going to consider that maybe I should
pause. I don't know. I'm going to pray about that because it did what it was supposed to do. And
now you're going to take over from here. I don't know. So there's pros and cons to everything. So
really pray about that. I don't have an answer for that. I'm very tired having COVID. Any suggestions
to help me build back my COVID, my fatigue app? Well, one thing that can be very good for post COVID
fatigue is the clear talks. Okay. Pulling that out of there, the liberal, liberal, liberal
kinase in the nano kinase can be very helpful for that. Increasing blood circulation with a
product like that and garner good things like that can be very helpful. Oxaloacetate has been
found to be extremely helpful for post COVID fatigue. Oxaloacetate is sold in a product called
Benagine and a product called Oxaloacetate CFS for chronic fatigue syndrome. So you try the
much lesser Thor misphoric dosage called Benagine first, much less expensive too. And I would give
that a shot. We've had some people with really good results with that. Matter of fact, this Oxaloacetate,
I actually do an interview with a little bit who holds their company did a interview about a
year ago with him. I've been using Benagine for since it first came out years and years ago.
It has been proven to decrease tumors. And we have a number of our patients on Benagine
slashe oxaloacetate for that. Really good for brain tumors. First came out with a study with
aftersytoma and glioblastoma. And then it now has been proven with breast cancer and other cancers too.
I've been on the lube, immunotherapy for a mesotheliala, for about two to eight years.
A drug company recommends no more than two years when we crossed the tier year mark by liver
numbers started to rise. Last month my college is halted the treatment because the liver numbers were
high. And I don't know if it was because they had to live it at two years because of that reason
because it started to negatively affect the liver or not. But on Apparentezone yesterday to try to
bring those numbers down, any suggestions. Yeah, I would suggest you need liver support.
So if there's damage to the liver from a drug, you need to number one, do everything you can,
everything you know to help increase the detoxification of the liver. One of those hot packs of the
liver, confianabas, cancer opax on the liver. All your liver support supplements.
Ready the liver program in the normalizing frequency folder of the rife machine
using ion pro wave, doing sawdust. And if you're like doing all those, what else could I possibly do?
Another great help to rebuild the liver is liver tissue. So I mentioned this a few weeks ago,
decides for health has a new product called organ synergy, organ synergy. It's in capsule form and
it's in powder form. It just came up with a capsule form so we don't have that on the store. Yeah,
but the powder form we have on the store. And it has organ tissue liver and some other organs all
from bovine, sourced, New England, clean sourced animals. And that could be really helpful to help build
back the liver. But you need to really support those detoxification pathways. Every way you know how
every way that we've talked about, look at the detoxification course as well. And mainly the phase
one and phase two and phase three section of that course. And then think about supporting the liver
building back with with organ tissue. At many labs in my deck and growing, I requested an ultrasound
to make sure none of them are blood clots. After skating my arms and legs, I was told there are no
clots, but all are swollen lip nodes. Since I do have cancer in my lip, would these all possibly
probably be cancerous? Should I be addressing those lip nodes? Helping them drain, heal, etc.
Yeah, they could be cancerous, sure. So what's how do you know the difference to the swollen lip
node or a cancerous lip node? Well, the only perfect way to know is through a biopsy. But there's
some hints. So a swollen lip node typically will be more squishy. A cancerous lip node is going to be
or hard like a marble. So that's just one hint. Should I do lymphatic drainage? Should I do things?
Well, everything is you're already doing. I would not do lymphatic massage. In this case, I wouldn't
do. There's nothing else I would do except exercise motion and soda and everything else you're doing
supporting downstream from the lymph system, which is supporting the blood supporting the liver.
And that's phase one, two, three, four, five, six, making sure your bowel movements are going well
and making sure you're doing coffee animals. In the uncle type score, something I should pay attention to
is the uncle type score something I should pay attention to. Yes, it could give you some
clarity of whether you should do chemo or not. So if you had a score of, you know, a really high
score that would tell you that maybe, maybe chemo should be in your car in the car. If it's a really
relatively low score, then that would kind of confirm that you don't want to do chemo. So that's
the only way I would use it. I asked the oncologist. They're supposed to be looking at 21 genes
specific to tumors. Then why doesn't it tell me what they found seems a bit sketchy to me?
It's a newer test that came out a couple of years ago. And it's just how well you'll do with chemo.
So I don't, I don't actually understand that complete physics of the test itself. So I can't really
comment on that. I have my gallbladder, no gallstones. So just because you don't have gall, no gallstones
doesn't mean that you don't have sluggish gallbladder. So also consider that. And then
so I also, I do, if you want to try the liquid D, don't pay for it because I have cells that is
near expiration, they don't give you. So we'll throw that in and it's good for another five years
after that, but we can't sell it. So I have a bunch that that I forget rid of.
Since my third chemo last weekend, pains that come and go in my ovary regions,
like menstrual cramps, but I'm not menstruated in the year to half could this be from the coffee
enemas or from the vaginal yogurt infusions or an autoimmune issue beginning from the immunotherapy
or other ideas. And there's just no way that anybody could make that call with just the
toilet that you have pain in your ovary regions. I think it could be some different things.
So I just, I don't know. I mean, again, would you run some labs to see if you have antibodies to
you know, ovary tissue or rum, I wouldn't even do that when you're still doing people in
immunotherapy. You gotta let your body calm down before you even run any of those kind of labs.
Additionally, I have bumpy itchy head, chemo rash. So yeah, when you're the one who asked the
question about the yeast infections, you could also be some of the itchy's and rashes. All this
could be just negative effects of the chemotherapy and you detox the chemo therapy as well. So
before you make another diagnosis, you got to get through this piece. You got to kind of take
steps at a time. Yeah, you want to try to treat the symptoms well. So you're not miserable going
through this, but all these can be causes of the drugs that you're putting in your body.
My doctor who offers the pharmacotherapy says it's laser level four. He's good friends with Dr.
Colfelt, so he knows about Colfelt's way to do PDT. So I think Dr. Colfelt's way that he does the
PDT is the correct way. I think just using the level four laser is not photodynamic therapy in my definition.
So he wants me to take methylene blue and riboflabe of two hours prior to the procedure.
I don't know what color laser he uses. The color makes no difference. It would be a laser light going
through into my bloodstream, but I don't know what's in the IV bag. Unless it's super expensive,
I don't think it's any harm in trying that. But I would also ask the doctor if there's any benefit.
If you're only thinking of doing one or two sessions, there may not be very many benefit in doing
one or two sessions either. So you might have to ask the doctor know what the minimum amount of
sessions to see some benefit would be. My mercury fillings were all removed a few years ago,
being drilled out with no safety precautions by a traditional dentist. I had an appointment with
my biological dentist last week. I still have two crows. It show metal underneath the white caps,
my bio dentist said they were mixture of metals, but not mercury. He was not concerned about them.
What are your thoughts? Well, I would default to the biological dentist then if he knows that
they're not mercury. I forget you if you check for metal toxicity. Is it safe to whale pool?
If the metal is underneath the caps, that yes, it's okay to whale pool.
I met with an integrative doctor today about addressing my toxic mold issues. She has a whole
protocol of detox I need to go through and she wants me to pause some of the supplements I'm taking
from you until we have this done. She's concerned that it will be too much to keep
taking everything. Is it best to contact Megan and put a pause on certain supplements?
Tell her done with the mold detox. Okay, so I don't remember seeing a microtox test. I don't
remember if I went over a microtox test with you or not, but I'm assuming that that's what you're
talking about with a more toxic mold issues because let's make sure we're defining our terms and I
know sometimes doctors simplify and maybe I overcomplicate so I apologize, but I think clarity is
important. So a lot of doctors say you have toxic mold issues. That's what we need to detox. Nobody
has molded their body. So a microtox test is tested for what are called microtoxins, which are
toxins that mold produces. So exposure to molds produce these chemicals called microtoxins. They're
not molds, they're chemicals. So if you show elevated microtoxins on a microtox test,
the first thing that you need to do is to make sure you're not, you don't have any
current exposure or any detoxification that you do will be for not. Zero nothing. You have to make
sure you address current exposure. So if you have current exposure, black mold, or aspergillous
or any of the molds that are listed on that test that produce these different microtoxins,
no business trying to do any detox. So that's number one. Then number two, then you start pulling
these microtoxins out. It's not a simple procedure that you're going to reduce these in 90 days by
just taking some medications or some different pills. So beware of that too. So you need
objective testing. So they better do a post microtox test to look at evaluate that.
So if that's what this doctor is doing, then that's your choice. Then by all means, you can do that.
But if they're, for some reason, saying that it's just concerned me about that term that you
use, maybe it's just a term you use there, but I've heard that before where people go, I went to
this doctor and they said, I have, I'm old toxicity and I have to do this because I have to get
kill this mold in my body. That's, that's just not right. So, so I apologize for explaining that.
It might not have anything to do with you or what your doctor is doing. It might be fantastic,
but it's one of the clarify that for other people. Because people do the microtox test that they
think they have mold in their body. And it's they have microtoxins in their body from molds that
they've been exposed to. So that's what you want to get rid of. Should I continue with the
kendison forte for my yeast infection? I have very low body for it. I would say no, wait on it
until after you're done with your chemo and immunotherapy. Why is chemo given systemically and not
directly injected into the tumors? Because they're treating your whole body and I don't know of any
chemos that are directly injected into tumors. Doc emailed back. It will be a fiber optic through.
Okay, so that's good. So the fiber optic, that's good. So I would, but the next question I would ask
you is just what I said is to do the to ask of what how many treatments do you think it should be.
I did have the microtoxid as you have a copy. Okay, I'll look at that too. I do plan to check the
house and make sure not get any additional exposure. Especially somebody like you there because you
you've been doing so much detox over time. And if your levels are still very elevated, my concern
would be you have current exposure or recent exposure. So somebody that, okay, it hasn't been doing any
detoxification has been living to average American life and got sick and other going through some
sicknesses. If you do a microtox test and it's elevated, well, that could have been from an exposure multiple
years ago, right? But for somebody who's done so much work on detoxification, I guess you could say,
well, it could have been much higher elevated, you know, a year ago, and that is true too. So but you
do want to just rule out current exposure, just make sure. All right, and you know, for everybody who's
looking at mold as an issue, I do have go to our blog post and type in mold and you'll see I did
an interview with a great company that does mold testing where you, they said you little
petri dishes that you do that they're really a good company and they're fairly inexpensive. So look
at that. How do I get HCl and from where do I get this? The HCl that I would recommend is a product called
Clear Digest, Clear Digest. That's our product. And you'd only take any HCl product, you only take
with your meals. You don't take HCl and an empty stomach ever, any product that has HCl and you don't
take an empty stomach. Clear Digest is the product. Okay, with that, I think we will say goodbye.
I pray for all of you and we'll see you guys next week.